let's say i have a horizontal pipe
that and at this at the left end of the
pipe
let's say the left end of the pipe
the area
the cross-sectional area so i'll call
that area one
let's say that that is
i don't know
it's equal to
two meters
yeah let's use simple numbers two meters
squared
let's say it tapers off
it tapers off
so that the
area the cross sectional area at this
end of the pipe
so area two
is equal to
i don't know half a meter half a square
meter
and let's say that
you know just the typical
you know we have some velocity at this
point in the pipe which is v1 and then
the velocity exiting the pipe is v2 and
let's say that the external pressure at
this point
essentially being applied rightwards
into the pipe let's say that pressure 1
is i don't know let's say it's
it's
let me
right in the bold color let's say it's
pascals and let's say that the pressure
at this end
so the pressure too and so that's the
external pressure at that point in the
pipe let's say that that is equal to
i don't know let's say it's equal to
6000 pascals
right
and so given this information let's say
we have water
in this pipe
there's just generally so i could just
draw
water and we're assuming it's laminar
flow so there's no uh a friction within
the pipe and there's no turbulence and
all of that so using that what i want to
do is i want to figure out i want to
figure out how much what is the flow or
the flux of the water in this pipe so
how much volume goes
either into the pipe per second or out
of the pipe per second and we know that
those are going to be the same numbers
because of the the content the equation
of continuity so we know that the flow
which is r
which is volume per amount of time
that is the same thing as the input
velocity times the input area
right
so the input area is 2 so it's 2
v
and that also equals the output area
times the output velocity so it equals
one-half
v2
and then we could we could rewrite this
that v1
is equal to one-half r
and that v2 is equal to 2r so this
immediately tells us that v2 is is
coming out of at a faster rate
right
just based on the the size of the
openings and then we also know
because v2 is coming out at a faster
rate but we also know because we have
much higher pressure at this end at this
end that the water is flowing to the
right
the pressure differential the pressure
gradient is going to the right so the
water is going to spread out of this end
and it's coming in at this end
so let's use bernoulli's equation to
figure out what the flow through this
pipe is
so bernoulli's equation let's just write
it down
p1
plus rho
rho
g h1
plus one half
rho
v1 squared is equal to
p2
plus rho g
h2
plus
one half
rho
v2 squared
well this pipe is level right the height
at either end is the same so these h1 is
going to be equal to h2 so these two
terms are going to be equal so we can
cross them out we can subtract that
value from both sides and we're just
left with
p1 and what's p1 p1 is ten thousand
pascals so let's start substituting
numbers
ten thousand
pascals plus
one half
row times v1 squared well what's v1
well that's r over 2. we figure that out
up here
so v times r
over 2
squared
is equal to p2 that's 6000 pascals
plus one-half
rho
times v2 squared we figure out v2 is v2
is 2r
2r
squared let's just do some
simplification so let's subtract 6000
from both sides and we're left with 4
plus let's see
we get r squared
over four and then a one half
so we'd have rho
r squared over this is a over four over
one half so this over eight
is equal to
ready to subtract the six thousand from
both sides
so we'll have one half times r squared
times 4 so this is 2
rho
r squared
see we could
multiply
both sides of this equation by 8 just to
get rid of this in the denominator so
we'd get 32
plus rho
r squared
is equal to
16 rho
r squared
and subtract rho r squared from both
sides of this equation we get 32
000 is equal to
well this is 1 rho r squared this is 16
rho r squared so this is
rho
r
squared
and then what's rho what's the density
of water well the density of water is is
one thousand kilograms per meter cube so
this is one thousand
so let's divide both sides by 15 times
rho
so let me draw let me switch colors
so we get r
squared
is equal to 32
divided by 15
row row is a thousand so r squared is
equal to
000. over 15
000 which is the same thing as 32 over
15.
so r is equal to the square root of 32
over 15. it's going to be meters cubed
per second
let's see let me get my calculator
and the calculator did i
actually remove my calculator i think i
did
let's get my calculator going
so i get
divided by 15
is equal to
2.1 and then i take the square root of
that 1.46
so the answer is
r
is equal to 1.46
meters cubed per second so that is how
much what is that's the volume of water
that is either entering the system in
any given second or exiting the system
in any given second and we can figure
out the velocities too right what's the
velocity exiting the system
what's 2 times that so it's like 2.8
meters per second exiting the system and
going in it is
it is half that so it's like 0.8 meters
per second
but anyway hopefully that that gives you
uh well actually 0.7 meter per second
that gives you a bit of an intuition
more intuition on fluids and
that that's all i'm i'm going to do for
today i'll see in the next video and
we're going to do some some stuff on
thermodynamics